narcolepsy is a disorder that affects
many different areas of life so in
typical patients with narcolepsy they
have something called excessive daytime
sleepiness so they're very sleepy during
the day yet at night they're still
sleepy but their sleep is very broken so
we'll see patients with narcolepsy
you'll see the classic narcolepsy with
cataplexy as we call it
when patients will have they'll just
fall asleep right away so if there's a
loud noise a strong emotion happiness
anger fear can actually make their
bodies shut down and have muscle
weakness that they fall asleep other
patients it's not that severe they'll
have a lot of muscle weakness so I have
one patient who used to hear a loud
noise when she was at work and her right
side of her face used to become numb and
weak so there are a lot of symptoms that
happen with narcolepsy we're not fully
we're starting to learn what's causing
it there's something in our bodies in
our brain called hypocretin and they're
saying that people who have cataplexy so
that muscle weakness those patients tend
to have a lack of hypocretin it
decreases even more as they age so we
don't really know why it's happening but
that's one theory as to what might be
going on other things that happen in
narcolepsy is they tend to have very
vivid dreams so when they do fall asleep
and they take those really brief naps
that are very refreshing so even a
five-minute nap is completely refreshing
for these patients but the minute they
go into sleep they dream and they have
very vivid dreams during the day and
night more so than most patients do
narcolepsy is really hard though because
they're very sighs they're very tired
during the day they're sleepy during the
day and it's managed mostly with
medication so we use medications to help
them sleep better at night and to stay
awake during the day but there are
behavioral things you can do also by
changing diet exercise having an actual
nap schedule but it can be difficult
because patients want to work they want
to have functional lives and to have a
discussion with an employer about being
able to take a quick nap it's refreshing
to help them be more energetic during
the day is actually a real problem so
sometimes we'll have to work with
employers to help them see that
narcolepsy is a real diagnosis families
will often call patients lazy so it's
really a it's a disorder that affects
not just the patient but marriages
families workplaces it it can really
affect a lot of
people